Donald Trump has hit a humiliating
seven-year low in polling as Joe Biden
is seeing his approval rating climb
since the 2022 midterms there's really
interesting Dynamics developing in
National politics this is not about the
2024 election this is about how it is
interesting to think historically of
circumstances in which current or
out-of-office elected officials see
dramatic changes in approval rating and
to understand what precipitates that so
let's start with the news CNBC reports
Trump hits seven year low in the new
National poll as Biden approval climbs
about a month after launching his 24
campaign Trump standing with voters has
hit its lowest point in more than seven
years this is according to a Quinnipiac
University poll released yesterday only
31 percent of registered voters surveyed
hold a favorable view of trump
verses 59 unfavorable that's the lowest
rating Trump has received since July
2015. shortly after we launched his
first presidential bid so two ways to
interpret that one historic low and
Trump is going down in flames
Counterpoint this is as bad as it was
for Trump when he started running in
2015 and he ended up being president of
the United States so maybe we shouldn't
write it off uh meanwhile what about uh
Joe Biden Joe Biden's approval rating
still underwater is at its highest
rating since September of 2021.
um just 43 of respondents say they
approve of Biden 49 disapprove but that
is a significant increase from last
month and Biden has not yet announced
that he's running in 2024 but it is
increasingly looking that way and so
Trump down Biden up so
check out this list of ideas about how
someone can raise their approval rating
and I think you'll very quickly see why
it may be a problem for Donald Trump
effective leadership people seeing you
as doing effective leadership Trump's
not in office so that's going to be
really difficult
handling important issues well Trump's
not in office so it's going to be hard
to do that these are ways that people in
power can raise approval rating good
communication skills well sure I mean I
guess if Trump somehow became good at
communicating that would be useful uh
being responsive to constituents Trump
doesn't care about constituents that's
hilarious
um economic performance Trump's not in
power so it would be hard to do that so
given that Trump is not in office what
can elected officials out of office do
to raise their approval rating okay stay
visible and engage with the public even
if you're not in public office you can
become visible and engaged by doing
public events media appearances speeches
rallies Etc well Fox News and many other
prominent media don't seem to want to
interview Donald Trump and it's not
totally clear how quickly he is going to
go back to rallies but I guess
potentially holding rallies might be
something Trump can do although having 4
000 people go to see you speak I don't
know if that's really going to move the
needle nationally second
Trump can be vocal on important issues
even if he's not the one handling them
he can speak out about issues facing the
country Trump could do that except
mostly when he gets the opportunity to
speak the issues are the 2020 election
was rigged
we have a problem with men in women's
sports as he likes to say it
and the country is now communist
not exactly the type of stuff that's
going to raise your approval rating and
then lastly Trump can build a strong
team that inspires confidence and there
are rumors Trump might soon announce who
would be his VP I don't know if he's
going to do that we'll see
but often it seems as though Trump's
team is getting worse and that right now
it's a very ragtag low end team even
compared to what he had in 2016 and
2020. the additional problem Trump has
right now
is that there's a significant faction of
the Republican party that's preemptively
breaking away for Ron DeSantis even
though Ron DeSantis hasn't announced
that he's running for anything yet so
it's going to be tough
it's not looking great for Donald Trump
but I think the important thing is if
Trump does get the nomination the people
that break away for DeSantis mostly will
fall in line and vote for Trump because
they hate Democrats way more than they
dislike Trump one of our sponsors today
is Bluetooth a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz on their
website a licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA the entire
process is just a few clicks go to
bluetooth.com the link is underneath
this video they'll give you an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code Pacman all you have to do is
pay five dollars shipping